in today is morning rounds the fight to
stop one of the leading causes of death
in the u.s. in 2016 nearly 10 million
adults said they had serious thoughts
about trying to take their own lives now
an old drug is being used in a new way
to help people in the desperate grip of
depression and the results have been
astounding researchers Paula Reid as the
story and Stallings says she's been
battling severe depression for most of
her life she tried antidepressants and
even electroconvulsive therapy but
nothing worked until she came to this
Potomac Maryland clinic and tried
ketamine it was like the fifth treatment
in and I had come home from the grocery
store groceries and I was like wow this
is how you don't feel depressed it was
like turning from a black-and-white TV
to a color TV
ketamine was approved by the FDA in the
1970s to sedate patients during medical
procedures it's more commonly known as
an animal tranquilizer and in powder
form as Special K a club drug used to
get high today ketamine is being
provided legally off-label to treat
depression at an estimated 250 clinics
across the US so in an average day how
many patients you have across all the
offices we see about 10 to 12 in this
office and across all of them dr. Steve
Levine offers intravenous ketamine
infusions at several clinics around the
country as an alternative to common
antidepressants everything for the past
50 years has been based on the chemical
imbalance theory of depression which has
never held water so all of these
medicines while they do help a lot of
people are based upon a flawed theory
and that's probably one of the reasons
why they do take so long to work they
all take weeks to months to work so
here's a medicine that people can take
infrequently that is based upon a theory
of the brain that makes a lot more sense
and it works almost immediately
Stallings didn't have time to wait
she had an especially hard time over the
holidays and when her father got sick
she thought about taking her own life
and actually had suicidal ideations the
one thing about ketamine was that I was
able to get in here emergently because I
knew what was going on and when I left
here the suicidal thoughts were gone so
you had suicidal thoughts you got an
emergency appointment for ketamine and
after that appointment your suicidal
thoughts were gone
yes gone that's in line with what
Columbia University discovered in one of
the largest studies yet on ketamine
researchers found the drug was
significantly more effective than a
commonly used sedative in reducing
suicidal thoughts in depressed patients
the effects lasted up to six weeks
22 year-old Mark Nelson ditched his
antidepressants for ketamine and talk
therapy he says he now feels more like
himself but it came at a cost
he has spent more than ten thousand
dollars on treatments so many different
drugs that I am now off of all of them
which you know the side effects just
were not tolerable to me they're making
me a zombie I was not happy
but these infusions can have their own
pitfalls you know the 45-minute period
of very floatiness I sometimes get
nauseous they give me a pill for that
ketamine can cause people to feel
detached from their bodies it's a very
interesting process
Hasso in the fact that i just lost my
train of thought
which is why we had to pause our
interview until Nelson completed his
treatment so how you feel it clear
cognizant and definitely able to
pronounce my words there are going to be
some critics who say that perhaps you
were just making money by giving people
the opportunity to get high what do you
say to that I would say that if you ask
any of our patients none of them feel
that they're getting high people tend to
focus on the party use of ketamine
because it's more exciting it's sexier
in some way it does it a disservice
because that's a very very small
fraction of its use and as far as the
money making aspect of this if you're
doing things in the right way
you're not going to make a lot of money
ketamine has piqued the interest of
several major pharmaceutical companies
there are half a dozen drugs in
development that would mimic the way
ketamine works some of them are
currently undergoing FDA clinical trials
as antidepressants so what we're trying
to understand is what does it change in
the brain that allows that sustained
antidepressant like response for decades
dr. jerry santa cora has been studying
ketamine at yale he says the drug is not
addictive in the way opioids are but
could still be harmful in the long run
there is at least evidence and animal
models that these type of medications
can actually cause some structural
damage in the brain that's usually had
higher doses it's usually a longer term
exposure but we don't know where that
level is dr. Levine says he monitors
patients closely in our population even
people who've been having ketamine on a
maintenance basis for up to six years
now we haven't seen any sign of that but
for an stallings despite the unknowns
she's content with a chance to feel
normal if I can live a quality happy
life and be productive the other door
to be able to have my family to enjoy
life not walk through life but enjoy
life and it's worth it for CBS this
morning Saturday Paula Reed Potomac
Maryland it's really pretty fascinating
yeah
really exciting field of study I think
we're gonna see a lot more on that front
in the coming year and and life-changing
for what that